the scp foundation has a reputation for
cold inhumane conditions but being
contained as an anomalous human doesn't
mean your stay inside a secure facility
has to be as bad as it might seem at
first of course more dangerous anomalous
entities such as scp-076
code named able are locked away in a
containment chamber outfitted with
maximum security precautions and guarded
by the foundation's most well-trained
and heavily armed personnel but not
every anomaly poses a danger and the
foundation realizes that sure the
monsters like scp-106
or
scp-096 who need no introduction aren't
exactly treated to a bed and breakfast
every morning but those lower on the
danger scale can get pretty comfortable
inside their new home depending on how
well they're behaved and how little of a
threat they pose of course take for
instance
scp-076's less violent brother
scp-073 also known as kane
scp-073 is peaceful a complete contrast
to
scp-076's destructive fits of violent
enrage and as a result he's treated like
nearly any other low threat anomalous
humanoid amenities clothes maybe even
some time in the foundation's
recreational spaces if they're extra
well-behaved it's true that the
foundation has been doing a lot for the
anomalies it contains especially in
recent years after all anomalies
contained by the foundation are
containment breaches aside supposed to
be contained for life the least the
foundation can do with all of their
seemingly infinite money and funding is
show them an easier time while they're
in there sometimes anomalous humanoids
are integrated into the foundation's
command structure such as the case with
a mysterious dr clef a former global
occult coalition agent turned foundation
operative with reality bending powers
and a pension for neutralizing dangerous
anomalies or dr jack bright who
continued to work as a foundation
researcher following an accident with
scp-963
an amulet that made his consciousness
immortal or kane pathos crow once an
ordinary foundation scientist now a
golden retriever blessed with super
intelligence thanks to an experiment
gone wrong or right depending on who you
ask it is true the foundation is
definitely more accepting of the
anomalous than it may initially seem
let's take a look at a particularly
notable anomaly contained by the
foundation
scp-166 can be seen as a baseline
example of how the foundation treats the
average humanoid anomaly that doesn't
pose a significant threat to the
organization or society at large
scp-166 is contained at the famous
site-19 inside a hermetically sealed
anti-chamber outfitted with an
industrial air purifier personnel
assigned to
scp-166's containment chamber must wear
specially designated biohazard suits
before entering and keep them on at all
times lest they succumb to
scp-166's anomalous effects
scp-166 is a teenage girl of european
descent possessing certain bodily
features found on a reindeer she has
antlers hooved feet and a short tail all
that's missing is a red nose right but
despite looking like one of santa's most
trusted four-legged helpers
scp-166 has little to do with the animal
in fact scans of her dna reveal no
irregular genetic traits to the
instruments used to record such things
she is a completely ordinary human her
reindeer features are according to some
foundation theorists a reflection of her
connection with nature and a remnant of
her past but we'll get to that aside
from her fluffy parts what makes
scp-166 so anomalous as it turns out
scp-166 possesses an incredibly strong
anomalous ability any artificial objects
meaning those that are man-made within a
15-meter radius of
scp-166 will return to an unworked state
for example a car placed with an scp-166
range will return to a composite of
paint metals leather and plastics over
time these higher complexity objects
such as vehicles or electronics are
affected more quickly by scp-166
with degradation of their metallic
components giving out and causing
massive structural failure resulting in
an unusable object more natural objects
made of rudimentary materials such as
stone buildings and products made of
organic materials will decay at a much
slower nearly imperceptible rate so
scp-166 containment chamber and
containment solution is more than safe
though it might need to be repaired and
touched up over the years
scp-166 is very in touch with nature as
her appearance would suggest in fact in
areas where objects degraded as a result
of her influence flowers and plant
growth will begin to appear sometimes
this foliage will grow in places that
should otherwise be impossible for it to
such as id scanners or security cameras
you could imagine that the inside of the
chamber is practically a botanical
garden still the foundation has to be
careful with how
scp-166's containment chamber is
constructed and who enters it as the
degrading deer girl harbors a particular
sensitivity to artificial materials and
pollutants such as smoke or pesticides
inhalation of or contact with one of
these airy substances causes
scp-166 to grow ulcers and suffer
symptoms of asthma attacks even being in
close proximity with a smoker can cause
scp-166 pain with one instance prompting
a severe asthma attack despite the
foundation doctor in question having not
smoked a cigarette in over three weeks
if you need another reason to stay away
from smoking do it for
scp-166 isn't she adorable you wouldn't
want to give her a panic attack would
you not only are
scp-166's visitors limited and screened
beforehand but her clothing consists of
organic cloth so as not to trigger a
degradation effect all for meals must be
prepared by a trained foundation chef
and followed according to a specific set
of guidelines with as little inorganic
additives as possible the foundation has
to be a bit more careful than usual with
the items requested by scp-166
not only due to her anomalous ability to
degrade objects but due to her
mysterious past in connection with a
small convent of nuns in ireland we'll
explain you see like most humanoid
anomalies the foundation has allowed
scp-166 to put in requests for personal
items she might find missing from her
containment now the foundation may deny
these items for a variety of reasons but
there's also a chance they won't to date
scp-166 has requested a copy of the holy
bible a catholic rosary and various
books and magazines involving religious
content all of which were approved by
site 19's director sophia light
scp-166 also requested access to a
catholic priest for confession mass and
other sacraments
this request was initially denied but
later reapproved after chaplain davis an
ordained member of the clergy working
with the foundation agreed to meet with
scp-166 on a bi-weekly schedule every
other sunday scp-166
also requested a telephone which she
intended to use to contact the abyss of
our lady of mercy convent a cloistered
society of nuns in county galway ireland
this request was a little more
complicated to process at first it was
denied then granted and then denied
again after a reconsideration by
director light but why did
scp-166 want this item what connection
could the dear girl have to a group of
nuns in ireland the answers lie in the
foundation's discovery of scp-166
scp-166 was discovered in the our lady
of mercy convent in county galway
ireland where the girl had been living
since infancy her strange appearance and
abilities initially made her the subject
of scrutiny by the sisters who lived
there but she was taken care of and
raised as a member of the catholic faith
when the foundation was alerted to
scp-166's existence a defecting global
occult coalition agent operating under
the code name ukulele who is now in the
process of joining the foundation
confirmed that he recognized scp-166
he knew that scp-166 was the child of an
incredibly dangerous entity classified
by the global occult coalition as threat
entity 9927 black a being codenamed the
goddess the goddess also was being
pursued by the scp foundation and given
a designation as an scp object though
its number and the exact details of the
file have been redacted by the
foundation for security purposes what we
do know is that the goddess was a
seriously dangerous entity and both
parties were dedicating as many
resources as possible to its capture
containment or neutralization the
conflict between the goddess the global
cult coalition and the scp foundation
came to a head during an event known as
the cornwall incident the goddess's file
which was received and archived by the
scp foundation has a portion describing
as cp 166 which reads as follows threat
entity is the child of incarnated lte
9927 black the goddess and an unknown
father while it strongly resembles its
mother and shares its animalistic
features it lacks the extreme bestial
appearance of 9927 black possesses minor
chlorokinetic abilities but primary
reason for threat entity classification
is the instinctive knowledge and
eligibility to enact occult procedure
clockwork black child havilah a
worldwide ritual working that would
irreversibly regress human civilization
to neolithic standards strike team
lancelot neutralized 9927 black in
england during an operation which would
later be known as the infamous cornwall
incident but were unable to confirm the
liquidation of 9927 black child due to
the death of the strike leader agent
ukulele ukulele was posthumously awarded
the silver aegis for his lifelong
service to humanity as the file stated
scp-166 is the child of the goddess and
the reason for her anomalous degradation
abilities is so that she can enact them
on the world and fulfill her mother's
unholy mission a ritual that would
regress society to prehistoric times
ridding the world of modern technology
and man-made creations why the goddess
wanted to carry out this ritual is
unknown but scp-166 was her key to
achieving her primitive desires through
her child she could reach her goals but
the cornwall incident threw a wrench in
the goddess's plans agent ukulele a
global occult agent famous for
decommissioning dangerous anomalies was
tasked with killing scp-166
perhaps it was her human appearance or
the fact that she was only a small child
or even something that lay even deeper
ukulele could not bring himself to
terminate
scp-166 he defected from the global
occult coalition faking his death and
taking
scp-166 alongside him entrusting her
care to the convent of nuns ukulele made
himself scarce relieved that
scp-166 was safe after being free from
the global cult coalition's grasp
ukulele was unsure of what to do with
his life taking the name alto clef
ukulele had rid his previous identity
from the anomalous world and was
prepared to start a new life but he
couldn't let
scp-166 live unattended what if the
global cult coalition found her and
terminated her in an act that would
finish what they had started all those
years ago what if the foundation
discovered her he didn't want to risk
the girl being put into a life of
containment that she never wanted clef
decided that he made the best decision
and kept
scp-166's existence to himself as best
he could but his hand was forced not
long after
scp-166 at the age of 12 was seen by a
civilian visiting the convent who
reported her existence to the
authorities the foundation became aware
of scp-166
clef wanting the best for scp-166
exchanged valuable global occult
coalition intelligence documents and
information with the foundation in
exchange for
scp-166's containment and guaranteed
safety it was the best he could do for
the girl clef then fully defected to the
scp foundation where his skills were
heavily in demand soon as cp 166 was
retrieved from the convent and brought
into containment at least now clef could
know she was safe the cornwall incident
resulted in the termination of the
goddess and all parties were relieved
that the world was rid of this dangerous
and mysterious entity but it also
brought clef a significant amount of
strife why did he save scp-166
why was the battle hardened and brutal
assassin unable to kill her what
connection did clef share with the
goddess if any
scp-166 often wondered about the exact
details of her past she wasn't privy to
her history with clef or all the details
of her birth or what arcane ritual she
was born to carry out
scp-166 only knew the convent her faith
in the catholic religion and her life in
the custody of the scp foundation during
her talks with chaplin davis she often
discussed these feelings and desires to
know more about herself and her past the
foundation kept further details about
the goddess and her past under
restrictive classifications and attempts
to pry deeper never bore
scp-166 any fruit one conversation
between
scp-166 and chaplain davis was
particularly noteworthy inside the small
confessional where the two met every
other week they exchanged greetings and
began talking scp-166
enjoyed her talks with chaplin davis
which allowed her to explore her faith
and further her appreciation of it it
also gave her an opportunity to talk
about her feelings and thoughts in an
environment similar to the ones she was
raised in to start davis reminded
scp-166 that information she gave him
could be reported higher up in the
foundation if need be in the catholic
religion confession is a confidential
space but for the scp foundation the
rules of the church are often broken as
usual i have to remind you that due to
our environment the seal of confession
will not take place unless specifically
invoked even then details of our
conversation can be unsealed if they're
determined to be essential understand
davis said
scp-166 understood and nodded her head
first
scp-166 asked a question about a
replacement for pope benedict who
announced his retirement at the time of
the interview chaplain davis responded
ah yes that was rather unfortunate but
it does make sense my child he was
rather old even when he first took up
the position now he can rest knowing he
served the church well
scp-166 was curious to know if a
replacement had been decided davis
informed her that while there was
speculation one had yet to be decided
for certain though he was sure the
church would want to go forward with a
fresh new face to broaden its mission
scp-166 seemed pleased at this but
chaplain davis sensed an underlying
discomfort in the girl she wasn't
speaking her true feelings he assured
her that whatever question she had he
could answer to the best of his
abilities and without any judgment
scp-166 decided to speak up she wanted
to know if chaplain davis had a good
relationship with his parents davis sat
back for a moment and thought carefully
about his response as he did with all
questions that could cause an emotional
response in scp-166
no topic was more sensitive for scp-166
than the matter of her heritage davis
informed her that he maintained a good
relationship with his mother before she
passed away and a less than happy
relationship with his father davis asked
scp-166
about her parents diverting the
conversation away from himself he wasn't
sure at this point exactly how much
scp-166 was told or new in fact the
foundation didn't even let chaplain
davis know the full context of
scp-166's origins i never really knew my
parents said scp-166
i got dropped off when i was a baby i
mean i guess they must have known the
sisters if they put me there but i don't
remember them just what i picked up they
mentioned my mother a bit before they
realized they should watch what they say
about me i think they said something
about her being a goddess which
obviously wouldn't be true she must have
been some sort of spirit but she must
have been something if i ended up
looking like this i remember
eavesdropping on the abs she was talking
to one of the other sisters about how
she had done something wrong something
about a ritual that someone else stopped
they said she died davis taken aback by
scp-166's revelations told the girl that
he was sorry for her loss
scp-166 said that it wasn't like she
knew her anyway so she wasn't bothered
by it all that much davis asked about
her father but scp-166 also had little
information on him she said that she had
asked the abbas about him multiple times
but she never mentioned
scp-166's father she wondered if her
mother the goddess was so horrible what
did her father do that made him
unspeakable
scp-166's questions would not go
unanswered one day a letter was found
inside her containment area it read i
first met your mother when we were
little more than children she had hooves
for feet and starlight in her eyes she
was beauty and nature incarnate and i
killed her with my own two hands eden
isn't a place it is a state of being
they wanted to take us back to it and i
stopped them i took paradise away from
us for a second time i have never
regretted my actions on that day except
one that when you first met me on that
day you saw your father put a bullet
into the head of your mother i make no
excuses only explanation you may not
have even remembered it but i'm telling
you now in the hope you understand why i
did what i did i hope you forgive me i
love you i wish i could have done more
for you the best i could do was leave
you in the hands of kind and loving
people and hope they would raise you in
my place from what i've seen they did
well i'm sorry you couldn't stay with
them i'm sorry they brought you to this
place i promise to do my best to make
sure your stay here is pleasant i
promise to keep you safe happy 16th
birthday
from your loving father dr cleff scythe
19's director sophia light gave cleff a
disciplinary interview for making
unapproved contact with scp-166
and writing such an emotional appeal to
the girl clef had been barred from
talking to
scp-166 and his superiors were even
skeptical about letting him work at the
same site as her light showed sympathy
for clef's dilemma for 16 years
scp-166 cleff's daughter was unable to
live her life normally because of who
she was he felt partially responsible
despite being one of the foundation's
most trusted and powerful agents capable
of sending a strike team anywhere in the
world and knowing secrets people would
pay billions to know clef was unable to
talk to his own daughter in the end clef
was subject to a minor disciplinary
infraction but the hope that he may one
day reunite with his beloved
scp-166 remains now go check out scp-407
the song of genesis and scp-6000 the
serpent the moose and the wanderers
library for more nature-inspired scps